Speaker 1: Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson
is proposing a different explanation to the
Mike Pence classified document situation. And
Tucker Carlson's theory really a hypothesis. But
sometimes we say theory colloquially is that Mike
Pence just happened to find these documents at his
house right now because Pence is in cahoots with
the Justice Department under Merrick Garland's
leadership to take attention away from what Joe
Biden did and to try to screw Donald Trump. We
are really learning a lot about propaganda this
week from Tucker Carlson. You might remember on
yesterday's show, we had a segment about the
floating space vagina. You and I would call it
a cloud, because that's what it was. But Tucker
Carlson found it extraordinarily disturbing.
That was an instructive view into right wing
fearmongering. Today, it's conspiracy theories.
Here's what Tucker Carlson had to say.
Speaker 4: He said that a few times.
Then just days ago, Mike Pence sent his personal
attorney to search his family's home in Carmel,
Indiana, for classified documents. Now, if Mike
Pence didn't think it classified documents,
why would he send his lawyer to go look for
classified documents? Hmm. We can't say for
certain, but it's entirely possible. In fact, it's
likely that Mike Pence was asked to do this by
federal prosecutors who are trying to build a case
against his old boss. Whoa. Now, the point would
be to show that not every federal official walks
off with state secrets. Donald Trump was uniquely
evil in that regard, as in so many others.
Speaker 1: And again, he's minimizing the
fact that the Trump situation is so dramatically
different than the Biden or Pence situations.
Stole versus misplaced refused to give
back versus immediately turned over used
lawyers to prevent returning the documents
versus used lawyers to immediately return
the documents. But Tucker doesn't want you
to think about any of those differences.
Speaker 4: Mike Pence didn't do it. So if that
was the plan and we suspect that it was right,
it backfired spectacularly because Mike Pence's
lawyer promptly discovered classified documents.
Oh. He immediately loaded these documents into
his car and drove them back to Washington to
hand them over to authorities. Mike Pence. Me?
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, you know, one of the things
about most of these conspiracy theories is that
they are either un falsifiable or unlikely to ever
be proven or disproven. And that fact becomes
part of the conspiracy theory. Let me explain
what I mean by that. Tucker Carlson says, you know
what? This could have been. This could have been
the Justice Department recruiting Mike Pence
in order to help build a stronger case against
Trump. So they said, go have your lawyer look for
documents. Your lawyer certainly won't find any.
And then our case that what Trump did is uniquely
bad will be a stronger case. Now, of course,
there is no evidence whatsoever of that, and
it is unlikely that there is ever going to be
evidence of that. The most reasonable explanation
for why there won't be evidence of that is because
Tucker Carlson made it up. But the way that Tucker
Carlson and his followers interpret these types of
falsifiable conspiracy theories is that when there
is no confirmation one way or the other, because,
again, there's no evidence. It's sort of like if
you said to me, David, can you give me proof that
you don't own a Lexus? And I would say to you,
well, it's hard to prove a negative, but I mean,
I can show you the car I do have and I can show
you the insurance for the car I have and you'll
see it's not a Lexus. And then you could go, Well,
it's not really proof you don't have a Lexus. You
also might have registered it under someone else
or you might have it stored in a different garage.
How can I prove a negative? And for a lot of
these conspiracy theories, the way it will go
is remember, Tucker proposed that thing that
the Justice Department was working with Pence,
and he never really was able to disprove it.
Well, right. But no proof was found that that
was going on. Yeah, but it's very suspicious
that they weren't able to clear themselves up
that well. But how do you prove a negative? It's
the exact same mechanism. The other and this is
common. Conspiracy theories are often based on at
least some premises that can't be disproven. And
what that leads to is whether or not the theory
is true. The people who follow it have no way to
verify its authenticity, and that becomes part
of the problem. So another clinic from Tucker
Carlson on how this stuff works. And remember,
his audience is uniquely suited to be targeted
by this type of stuff and when it comes to in
court. Fox News lawyers are quick to remind
courts that Tucker Carlson is not a newsperson.
He's doing entertainment using hyperbole and
nothing he says should be taken as literally the
truth because he's not doing news. But he does a
segment like this and all of a sudden, a huge
portion of his followers believe, Well, that
sounds right. It sounds like this was Pence in
cahoots with the Justice Department. There is no
such evidence. We'll take a quick break. We'll be
back after this with just a packed program today.